l'auteur des faits placé en garde à vue
a été déféré au parquet jeudi dernier
mais un examen pour homicide
involontaire
le juge des libertés et de la détention
a ordonné son placement en détention
provisoire
ses avocats font appel cette décision
signifie beaucoup les abolitions bon
goût de l'avant ce qu'on a pu lire dans
la biographie et qui mourra blessé ce
matin l'accusé ce père de famille est à
nouveau convoqué devant le juge des
libertés de la détention l'homme auteur
de cet homicide
j'ai pourtant d'une excellente
réputation il a présenté comme un bon
père de famille jovial et travailleur
vous étiez très très malheureux que lui
et concerne la bourde de l'argent on a
dit ce qu'on a décidé
de 10h santander parce que à mon avis le
plus souvent il ya des victimes qui sont
en voyage du cos depuis les voyous y
sont
la nature détention provisoire ou pas la
décision du juge des libertés de la
détention sera connue demain mardi